[Music]
The Descendants is taking over the world
but while we anxiously await for the
next movie to come out we should
probably learn more about this crazy
universe don't forget to give this video
a thumbs up and subscribe to the things
now
let's explain the descendants universe
the family tree okay let's start the
slightly complicated descendants family
tree since you should probably know
who's the kid of which famous Disney
villain or better yet an infamous Disney
villain get ready because it's a lot to
take in and understand I will try to be
as simple as possible our four so-called
protagonists of The Descendants series
are mal Evie Carlos and Jai mal is the
daughter of Maleficent the original
villain from Sleeping Beauty then we
have Evie the daughter of the Evil Queen
from Snow White
Carlos is Cruella De Vil son from a
hundred and one Dalmatians and Jay is
the son of Jafar from Aladdin
while these four are the main characters
we see throughout the franchise we also
get to know Ben the son of Belle and the
Beast Ben's also one of the most
important reasons why these kid villains
even attend auradon prep but we'll get
to that in just a bit there's also Emma
who's Ursula's daughter and then there's
Harry hook the son of the infamous
Captain Hook we'll also meet side
characters like dizzy whose Drucilla's
daughter and even Lonnie
Mulan's daughter the relationship okay
so let's talk about friendships and the
actual relationships between these
characters mal and Evie are best friends
however the four main characters are
very close with each other in the first
movie we meet Ben the king of auradon
Ben is the one who wanted to see more
harmony and allows the villain kids from
the Isle of the Lost to attend auradon
prep which is how mal Evie Jay and
Carlos are the first kids allowed to
attend by the end of the second movie
Ben and mouth fall in love in the second
movie mal finds out that the Isle of the
Lost is now ruled by uma mouths former
friend who was the leader of the gang
that also consists of Harry hook and Gil
the son of Gastel after a rocky
relationship with Ben mal returns to the
island to clear her head and try to get
back to her roots where she's confronted
by Emma Harry and Gil while it's not
directly revealed in the movies dole
Cameron Thomas Doherty and Kenny Ortega
came up with the story that harian
values today
which explains a lot of unintentional
chemistry the two characters have during
the second movie as the actors are
actually dating in real life we also
learned that uma is extremely bitter
that she wasn't allowed to attend
auradon prep like the other four and she
tries to take the ultimate revenge on
Ben and the rest of the characters
sounds pretty complicated doesn't it the
back story all the main characters also
have backstories tied to them being
raised by some of the biggest Disney
villains as the daughter of Maleficent
mal wants to please her mother and be
the best villain she can possibly be
Evie is too consumed by superficiality
and Jay struggles with stealing and
lying
Carlos is perhaps the most interesting
one as he's completely afraid of dogs
which is a direct result of being
involved in karela the villas of all
plants he's also the one who gets
ridiculed the most for not being up to
the villains standards and then there's
Erica who's completely obsessed with
this hook and while there was never a
direct reason to explain why it is
suggested that it holds a deep
connection to his father we are
expecting to see more backstories and
connections the villain kids have to
their parents in the future as well as
more interesting building kids on-screen
and that is all for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
tell us how you felt about this video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]